so we're gonna focus a little bit first
on like openings and how we start the
game so since you guys are not beginners
you're going to be telling me some
opening names see if you guys know some
yes the King's gambit which goes efore
a5 f4 now we know that the King's gambit
you're sacrificing a pawn for very fast
development so we're gonna be seeing a
couple of those what else yes here okay
and the Queen's Gambit is like the
sister of the Kings gambit they have
very similar ideas once very aggressive
the other ones very positional in the
aggressive games we have games where you
develop very quickly and you try to
checkmate your opponent in the others
you're just kind of developing and
letting your opponent develop as well
yeah the Spanish opening of course II 45
9 f3 Knight c3 Knight c6 Bishop b5 which
is one of the oldest ways we have of
opening the game it's very standard that
you put the bishop on b5 you put the
pressure on the knight on c6 which makes
ePHI weaker right because now I'm
threatening to take it after the trade
of the night yeah the Sicilian defense
yeah alright so do you know where the
name comes from Sicilia well to be fair
it is called Cecilia in a language so I
mean that that does kind of make sense
it's come it's called Sicily it comes
from Sicily which is a part of Italy and
this was popular in the southern part of
Europe when chess was beginning and it
became a very popular weapon later in
chess you this wasn't really popular
until like more into the 1900s but it's
a very popular opening nowadays it's
actually the best scoring opening
against efore at the Grand Master level
is the Sicilian defense that has a lot
of variations and a lot of theory yes in
the back
the fettuccine I have the feeling that's
more of a the fianchetto okay fettuccine
I think at the type of pasta and the
fianchetto
is a development of the bishop so when
you put a pawn forward one and then you
hide the bishop between it and the
bishop goes into the long diagonal that
we call it en Cato
you might hear it from a lot of people
called Afghan Chad oh that is wrong it's
a fianchetto okay
young Cato yes and it's not it's
definitely not a federal Cheney all
right yes the Kings Indian defense the
Kings Indian defense is a very modern
opening it's an opening that only
started becoming popular around the 50s
now there are many famous grandmasters
that favored the Kings Indian defense
among those the only world champions
that America has ever had anybody know
the name of the guy yes Bobby Fischer
there's an exhibit across the street you
should probably take a look at it Bobby
Fischer was one of the people that
really understood how to play the Kings
Indian defense those black use the one
that made it really really popular so
any other openings yes the nimzo-indian
then do you know where that comes from
nimzowitsch that's right so there was a
guy called nimzowitsch very very long
time ago in the early 1900s that came up
with the idea of instead of putting a
lot of pawns in the center developing
this Bishop to b4 in order to gain
control over the square F or it was a
more advanced way of playing and
nimzowitsch some Russian dude was
actually credited to being the father of
a lot of modern chess systems yes yes
the French the French is one of the
older lines and actually this was
popular even back in the old history of
chess it's supposed to be very solid a
little passive and it's still popular
nowadays among the GMs so it's it's a
defense that's been throughout all
history unlike a45 it kind of tries to
counter-attack the center a little bit
faster so the ideas that you have
support for d5 later in the position
very strategical games very close yes
the queen's indian so the queen's indian
is like a sister of the nimzo-indian the
only difference is that we instead of 93
bishop before white goes Knight f3
developing the other night and then
black goes p6 to develop this Bishop
from b7 you can see the similarities of
many openings they all try to develop
they all try to control the center in
the Indians mostly the nimzo-indian a
Queen's Indian black is going to be
fighting for the center indirectly
instead of putting pieces sorry instead
of putting pawns in the center he's
going to be attacking with pieces so for
example this Knight controls efore this
bishops coming out the bishop will trade
itself for this night so the white
doesn't have a lot of control over the
center etc etc anybody else yes the
English the English it starts with the
move c4 and this is a move that's more
popular among the grandmasters than it
is against amateurs and the reason we
don't recommend amateurs to play it a
lot is because it violates one of the
cue rules of development in chess and
which rule is that what doesn't it do
compared to others yes anybody you have
the back it's not really training
anything yeah in the back well it's not
going to bring the Queen unnecessarily
but you're right the only thing that
it's helping me develop is the Queen
right and the Queen doesn't really want
to go out so it's like why are you
pushing this pawn forward as I said it's
a little bit more advanced the English
is not something I recommend people that
are beginning to play chess to to play
so let's try another word yeah the what
the yes very close it's known as the
perk in America it's known as the Pitts
everybody everywhere else you can
practice how to make that sound later
it's efore d6 d4 and I get this is very
similar to the
French we're like black is giving up a
little bit of space but he wants to
counter-attack later all right
so usually they play either a five or
they just develop with Knight f6 both
very viable options so you have the
periods yes
the London is a common idea and actually
ex or former US Champion gotta calm sky
ever heard of that guy yeah
gotta calm ski favor the London openings
the idea is that usually you put the
Bishop on f4 and instead of fighting for
the center with the pawns and the
Knights he just develops very quietly
puts the bishop here puts the pawns here
and here brings out the knight etc etc
it's quite pass if it's a little more
positional but that's the kind of chess
comm skew likes let's say yeah on the
Green Bay Packers here the Italian
definitely the Italian unlike the
Sicilian it's a opening that's really
old
we know that the Italian was played way
back when chest was started playing this
one of the first openings ever tried and
the idea is that unlike the Spanish
where you're attacking the center with
the bishop the bishop controls the
center by putting it on c4 so it's known
as the Italian game it's one of the most
logical ways of starting chess and
you'll see a lot of amateurs and a lot
of scholastic level players play the
Italian but it's also used by top
grandmasters a lot of top grandmasters
still use the Italian yeah no you know
yeah the German who well the rather
European country I don't think there's a
German opening though is there no I
don't think so yes
the benoni so that's a little harder to
explain but yeah the benoni well you
guys know more than I thought this is
the Benoni the benoni defense is a very
modern type of chess this is again black
giving up space trying to counter-attack
later so you see how white already has a
lot of space in the center with this
advanced pawns and blacks trying to
break through in the center by putting
pawn on e6 this is a very modern type of
position and it's very wild a lot of
people that are crazy and attacking like
to play the benoni it's not for the
faint of heart
all right in the back this one okay this
is this actually has two names yeah it
depends on who you ask
if you ask people from America they
normally know it as the Petrov
I believe the Petrov whereas most people
and the rest of the world know it as the
Russian defense so I don't know why it's
called the Petrov here but that's what
they call it it's known as the Russian
everywhere else is there an opening trap
yeah the idea is that if you take and
you take that's a mistake right because
after Queen e2 9/11 then this way to
legal c6 right so that's a check and the
queenís get stuck right yeah now have
you guys ever heard of a famous Grand
Master called
B Chien on this Chien on this yeah he's
known as something that I cannot
pronounce - WA not on something like
that anon he was world champion and he
actually is famous because he's the only
one of the few grandmasters that while
being a Grandmaster lost the game in
five moves he was playing Alonso sapota
in the Olympia back many many years ago
he tried to play the petrov then after
Knight takes he didn't go here because
he knows that one but after d6 night
here Knight takes e4 this is quite
normal normal sapota play Knight c3 oh
it was six moves I guess Bishop f5 and
here Zapata played Queen e2 and he
resigned because he realized that he was
going to lose the night for example if
he defends the night I attack it again
and it's pin
right yeah so the only way yes yeah if
he goes Queenie seven there's a very big
problem ninety-five attacking the Queen
attacking the pawn so the Queen must
defend the pawn right but again there's
nobody preventing the pin just d3 any
other openings yes the fried liver you
know it's funny because the fettuccini
is not one with the fried liver is all
right the Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop c4
and I believe you guys call the fried
liver specifically this line right where
you d5 takes and Knight takes right and
Knight takes f7 is known as the fried
liver attack this is actually a crazy
crazy opening and we're going to look at
a game that was played a long time ago
so we're going to take a look at a
really old game this game is between
some guy called paularyo which was
actually one of the really good players
back in the 1600s does anybody remember
the 1600s were you alive in the 1600s
where for your parents alive in the
1600s yes wow that's impressive all
right so we're gonna take a look and
what is this opening called
fried liver attack now the idea of the
opening is that after the move Queen f3
check this King feels a little
uncomfortable because there's a pressure
on this night and the there's a check
right so the King has to go forward and
then you go Knight c3 attacking again
the knight on d5 and now the only way of
defending it is with this night this
night has to come to its rescue well so
you play Knight c7 and then d4 so this
is kind of like the most romantic type
of Chester is romantic chest and I don't
actually know why it's called romance
chest but it's when one side sacrifices
all of their pieces trying to get at the
opponent King this was a very popular
way of playing back when chess started
so after d4 c6 Bishop g5 was played and
again the problem for black is that he
needs to keep defending the knight on d5
whereas white is developing all of his
pieces so it depends what you want more
do you want to your King to be safe or
do you want to have an extra night I
don't know it's not so easy to say
always h6 takes pigs then long castle
notice how white brings all of his
pieces into the game he castles he's
letting his rook come in or else black
is still not playing with a lot of
pieces right so rook F 8 Queenie 4 and
now a mistake when you're ahead in
material always make sure your King is
very safe never keep grabbing material
here black thought okay this is a free
pawn so he played the move rook takes f2
but that's probably not such a good idea
after pawn takes e5 there's more
pressure on this Knight and notice that
when this night collapses the rest of
the position is really really bad
because somebody has to protect the King
and it's not so easy to see who mm-hmm
the Knights and not a lot of trouble so
check King b1 and then rook the two
trying to keep this rook from going into
the game
remove h4 check takes and it seems like
black is still up one piece right so
after Bishop h4 for a pawn Knight takes
d5 font X and rook takes now there's an
old idea and chess that the threat is
more powerful than the execution what
that means is that sometimes the threat
of doing something is actually more
powerful than doing it in this case
after rook takes d5 I'm threatening at
some point to check I could have checked
immediately but here paularyo is very
patient he plays rook takes d5 because
he knows that it's more powerful to give
a check with that rook later yes
and that's what happened after Queen g5u
played rugby six double check check with
the rook and check with the bishop
so after Keaney seven whether you played
the move rook g6 attacking this Queen
and attacking the pawns after Queen d2
check King f8 check King e7 and black
even though his upper piece let's
checkmate it why do I check why take the
bishop when you can track mate in one
I always check mate in one yes yeah
actually in this position the question
is instead of 9 e 7 could he go night
before and the answer to that is yes it
he could have and it's supposed to be a
better move but it's still very very
complicated actually even though this
game was played somebody that's good in
math tell me how long ago with this play
this was played in 1610 so he was played
in 1610 how long ago was this yes very
good 405 years ago even though this this
exact position was seen 405 years ago
there was a grandmaster game with this
exact position at the Olympiad last year
so you know it's important to learn from
the past that was the give a shear of
sulcus yeah yeah I'm right all right
so we're going to take a quick look at
one game and then you guys can go play
ok so has anybody ever heard of a guy
called
Napoleon
all right French French general 1800s
Emperor whatever okay Sookie yeah he was
white in this game and he was playing
general Vectron whoever that is and this
was this is already when Napoleon was
excited okay you can read about that in
a history book yes well you'll see all
right so we're gonna get this position
and actually nobody mentioned this
opening does anybody know what this
opening is called yes sorry
that's scotch that's right this is
called the Scotch opening so after
Knight takes d4 which is considered to
be a mistake nine takes d4 pawn takes
Bishop c4 was played and now remember
this is like old days in the old days
they didn't really like material they
liked attacking so they always will try
to bring in their pieces as quickly as
possible
Bishop c5 was played and then c3 the
idea of c3 is that if you take here I'm
simply going to take and develop so
queen e7 was played castles as in
Queenie five and here in Napoleon came
up with kind of a brilliant idea
yes he doesn't want to
in the back a little higher oh because
check isn't like check is and some is
check is in the goal of the game
so check is just check the goal of the
game is checkmate but that doesn't mean
that every check that you can give is
something you should give in this case I
think black was worried about c3 pawn
takes and then just castling and then
again Y doesn't care about material he's
simply putting his pieces out and maybe
he was a little scared of that I mean
it's it's a good it's not a bad move but
he just preferred Bishop c5 yes the roof
we here oh yeah he cannot take on e4
that's a good point
because of rook e1 right and then
there's a pin yeah
so after Queen e5 f4 was played and this
looks like a bad move but actually
nopony had a very good idea so this
happened check everybody understand this
check right yes Chuck Chuck maybe not
king h1 and then C takes b2 now why do
you think black doesn't care about his
queen he gets a new queen when he takes
the rook right so here Napoleon played
the move Bishop takes f7 Chuck
so if you take I play check right with
the rook and then I take your pawn and
then I'm up a queen so you have to first
move the King away somewhere he put it
on d8
Napoleon took only five then where try
and got a new queen on a one so now
blacks up a queen
sorry blacks up a rook and upon but in
chess that doesn't matter as much as
your king and here blacks King not so
safe
Bishop g8 was played and here
Baron retreated his Bishop he was afraid
that if he took on GA the move Queen d5
would win at least a piece and probably
the King doesn't feel very safe
so Bishop e7 was played Queen b3
defending the bishop on g8 also
threatening the move Bishop b2 because
the Queen would be will be trapped so a
5 foot splayed so the idea of this was
that if Bishop b2 a4 and now yeah the
Queen can later move so this will still
be okay actually but Napoleon found a
way better move rook F a check
Bishop takes f8 Bishop g5 check Bishop
e7 takes takes Queen f7 check King d8
and Queen FA checkmate
so it was like a battle of temple you
always have this strategy of attacking
doesn't matter the material yeah